[Musik]
manche glauben sein Name wä auf ein
saisonales zyanobakterium trichodesmium
ereterium zurückzuführen dass ihm
manchmal eine gewisse rötliche Färbung
verleiht andere glauben allerdings dass
sein Ursprung viel epischer und
dramatischer sei dass er mit all den
Ägyptern zu tun hätte die sterben
mussten als Moses die Israeliten rettete
und mit Gottes Hilfe die Wasser dieses
Übels teilte aber wie dem auch sei das
Rote Meer ist heute röter den je und das
nicht nur wegen seines Namens oder
seiner Farbe seht es euch an 19 dezember
2023 Angriffe im Roten Meer stellen eine
weitere Bedrohung für die Weltwirtschaft
da 20 dezember 2023 das Chaos am Roten
Meer treibt die Warenpreise für die
Weltwirtschaft in die Höhe Angriff auf
die Schiffahrt im Roten Meer sind ein
Schlag für den Welthandel im Jahr 2023
befuhren rund 24 000 Schiffe die Passage
was etwa 10% des weltweiten
seehandelsvolumens ausmacht dazu gehören
20% des weltweiten Containerverkehrs
fast 10% des Rohöls und 8% des
Flüssiggases 13 Januar 2024 us-mitär
greift weitere von den Hut die
kontrollierte Stellungen an nachdem es
Schiffe gewarnt hat Teile des Roten
Meers zu meiden 16 Januar 2024 Angriffe
im Roten Meer griechisches Schiff von
Raketen der hui Rebellen getroffen der
Vorfall ereignete sich nachdem das
US-Militär bekannt gegeben hatte dass es
während einer Operation in der
vergangenen Woche vom Iran gelieferte
Waffen beschlagnammt hatte die für die
hui bestimmt waren inzwischen haben die
USA weitere Ziele in den von den die
kontrollierten Gebieten im Jemen
beschossen der britische ölgigant shell
hat laut Wall Street Journal am Dienstag
als Letzter alle seine Öltransporte
durch das Rote Meer auf unbestimmte Zeit
ausgesetzt meine Lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer die hui Truppen haben
beschlossen Schiffe anzugreifen die das
Gebiet passieren um gegen Israels
Offensive auf Gaza zu protestieren die
hui sind eine der beiden Seiten die seit
Jahren im jemenitischen Bürgerkrieg
kämpfen sie gelten auch als der
jemenitische Arm des Iran in diesem Fall
handelt es sich nicht um eine kleine
Terrorgruppe sondern um eine gut
organisierte Kampftruppe mit jahrelanger
Kampferfahrung seht euch z.B dieses
Video an dass die Gruppe veröffentlicht
hat ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass es
hier nicht nur um improvisierte Raketen
oder Angriffe in schlecht vorbereiteten
Booten geht sondern um echte amphibische
Operationen es liegt auf der Hand dass
dies eine ernste Gefahr für die
Handelsschiffe darstellt die den
suuskanal in die eine oder andere
Richtung durchqueren mit anderen Worten
eine der wichtigsten schiffahrsruten der
Welt ist jetzt
bedroht المسلحه الينيه بعون الله تعالى
عمليه عسكريه في البحر الاحمر كان من
نئئحternehmen kündigen bereits an dass
sie diese Gewässer vorerst nicht mehr
durchfahren werden die weltgrößte räerei
mers setzt den Verkehr im roten mehr
nach Angriffen der Hus und wie euch
vorstellen könt natürlich wen die Rillen
lassen so sehr dass einige natooländer
eine groß angelegte Operation
organisieren um die Sicherheit in der
Region zu gewährleisten am 12 und 13
januar gingen die USA und Großbritannien
dann in die Offensive und führten eine
Reihe von Luftangriffen im Jemen durch
einen Tag nachdem der UN Sicherheitsrat
die huthi verurteilt hatte insgesamt
wurden fast 30 Zielorte getroffen mit
präzisionsgelenkten Bomben von
kampfschätz aus und marschflohkörpern
wie der tomhawk von Schiffen aus die
Alliierten nahmen Militärflughäfen
abschussbasen Logistikzentren
Munitionsdepots und
luftverteidigungssysteme ins unter
anderem auch in der Hauptstadt Sanaa und
der wichtigsten Hafenstadt hudaida Ziel
der Angriffe war die Schwächung der
Fähigkeit der hui Ziele am Roten Meer
anzugreifen es ging nicht darum die
Anführer oder die iranischen
Strippenzieher zu töten allerdings
mussten die USA bereits zugeben dass
dadurch nur 20 bis 30% der
offensivkapazität der hui beschädigt
oder zerstört worden sein und zwar da
sich die Ortung von huthi Zielen als
viel schwieriger erwiesen habe als
erwartet ein Großteil der
Offensivfähigkeiten der hui bleibt nach
us-angriffen intakt bei den von den USA
geführten Luftangriffen am Donnerstag
und Freitag gegen von der H Leas
kontrollierte Stellungen im Jemen wurden
etwa 90% der Ziele beschädigt oder
zerstört aber die Gruppe behielt etwa
dreiviertel ihrer Fähigkeiten Raketen
und drohen auf Schiffe zu feuern die das
Rote Meer durchqueren sagten zwei
us-amtsträger am Samstag die Stellungen
der huthi ausfendig zu machen erweist
sich als schwieriger als erwartet
amerikanische und andere westliche
Geheimdienste hätten in den letzten
Jahren weder viel Zeit noch ressourcenau
verwendet Daten über die Standorte der
Luftabwehr der huti der
Kommandozentralen der Munitionsdepots
unter Lager und Produktionsstätten für
drohen und Raketen zu sammeln aber wie
ist es möglich dass eine jemenitische
Rebellengruppe in der Lage ist eine der
wichtigsten schifffahrtsruten der Welt
LM zu legen wie schaffen sie es sogar
die mächtige US-Marine in Atem zu halten
was genau sind die huthi und welche
Gefahr stellen sie da heute werden wir
all diese Fragen beantworten und zwar
gleich nach der wichtigen Botschaft
unseres Trollen Sponsors zchar der
dieses Video erst möglich gemacht hat
denn solltet ihr noch kein VPN haben ist
dies nur die einmalige Gelegenheit es so
günstig wie noch nie zu bekommen muss et
ihr z.B dass viele Firmen wie Social
Airlines ganz unterschiedliche Preise
anbieten können je nachdem von welchem
Land aus man bestellt bzw sein Ticket
Bucht aber zum Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe eines
VPNs überlisten und dann richtig Geld
sparen und sur VPN ist ein wirklich
empfehlenswertes und sicheres VPN
welches z.B keinerlei Verbindungsdaten
mitlockt ein Virtual Private Network aus
VPN ist aber nicht nur zum geldparen
geeignet denn es kann einen auch vor so
mancher größeren gefahrschützen die im
Netz lauert natürlich muss man nach wie
vor Umsicht walten lassen und wissen was
man tut aber stellt hier für ein
Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen
da zum einen erschwert es in Kombination
mit anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktion im
Net nachzu verfolgen und abzuhören mit
Hilfe verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures
könnt ihr so eure Anonymität innz
erhöhen z.B mit dem integrierten cleanwb
das alle unerwünschen Cookies und Popups
blockt weiterer Vorteil des W ist dass
ihr so tun könnt als wäret ihr an einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr z.B auf Website
und Internet zugreifen die in dem Land
in ihr gerade seid gar nicht verfügbar
wären ob daheim oder im Urlaub damit
schlagt ihr Zensur und geoblocking ein
Schnippchen Netflix und andere streamin
die ihre Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten
von V Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfsar kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles denn mit nur einem
surfar Konto könnt wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte inf open registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politikde
angeht bekommt ihr von surfsag im Rahmen
dieses speziellen winterangebots auch
noch zusätzliche sechs Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nichts wie los besorgt euch
sursag und soft ab jetzt sicher und ohne
diskriminiert zu werden im Internet und
nun werft eure ten an wir begeben uns
ans Rote
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Meer wir haben in mehreren Videos
darüber gesprochen der arabische
Frühling ist mit großen Erwartungen
gestartet aber am Ende war er eine
Katastrophe die Krise mehrerer
autoritärer Regierungen in Nordafrika
und im Nahen Osten hat die Lage nicht
verbessert sondern in vielen Ländern ein
großes Chaos geseht wir werden euch
schon in Kürze hier auf visualpolitik
ein Video liefern was eigentlich aus
Libyen geworden ist tja und der Jemen
ist ein weiteres schlechtes Beispiel ihr
müsst nämlich verstehen dass die huthi
eine Gruppe aus dem Nordjemen ihre große
Chance sah als der arabische Frühling
2011 ausbrach damals erklärte der
damalige hui Führer Abdul Malik alhui
die Unterstützung seiner Gruppe für die
Demonstrationen die im Land entstanden
waren und den Rücktritt von Präsident
Ali Abdullah sali forderten gleichzeitig
übernahmen seine Männer die Kontrolle
über die nördliche Region Saada die zur
wichtigsten huti Hochburg werden sollte
und obwohl diese Gruppe an den Dialogen
teilgenommen hat die organisiert wurden
um das jemenitische politische System
nach dem Abgang von salich wieder
aufzubauen ist die Wahrheit dass sie
2014 zu den waffengriffen um gegen die
Regierung zu kämpfen so begann ein
langer und blutiger Bürgerkrieg zwischen
den hui und der jemenitischen Regierung
die schon bald Anzeichen enormer
Schwäche zeigte sie verlor sogar sehr
schnell die Kontrolle über die
Hauptstadt San a das Zwang Saudiarabien
und die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
dazu sich voll in den Krieg einzumischen
und das Ergebnis war eine Katastrophe
die huthi leisteten erbitterten
Widerstand und sie leisteten nicht nur
Widerstand nach und nach kam es auch zu
Scharmützeln auf See sagen wir einfach
dass das angreifen und karperern von
Schiffen eine doppelte Funktion erfüllt
einerseits kann dies Gruppen wie den
huthi helfen Finanzmittel zu erhalten
andererseits ist diese Aktivität eine
wichtige Quelle für Propaganda und
internationalen Einfluss im Jahr 2018
haben wir bereit Sicherheitsbewertungen
und Warnungen wie diese
erhalten die jemenitische Westküste
liegt am Roten Meer einem strategischen
maritimen Engpass durch den jährlich
fast 8% des Welthandels fließen darunter
auch wichtige
kohlenwasserstofftransporte die
asymmetrischen maritimen
Angriffstaktiken der hui bedrohen die
Sicherheit im südlichen Roten Meer und
ermöglichen es den huthi und ihren
iranischen Unterstützern ihre Gegner in
der strategisch wichtigen Wasserstraße
herauszufordern Anfang 2021 kurz vor
seinem Ausscheiden aus dem Amt hat die
Regierung von Donald Trump diese Gruppe
auf die Liste der terroristischen
Organisationen gesetzt was übrigens von
den Vereinten Nationen kritisiert wurde
weil dadurch die humanitäre Hilfe in dem
von den hui kontrollierten Gebieten
eingeschränkt werden könnte und der neue
Außenminister unter beiden Anthony
blinken hat diese Entscheidung Trumps
kurz darauf wieder rückgängig gemacht
doch angesichts der jüngsten eereignisse
stehen die Dinge jetzt wieder am Anfang
die USA erweggen die hust die nach der
schiffskarperung erneut als Gruppe
einzustufen aber lasst uns nicht
vorschnell urteilen um dieses riesige
durcheinander zu verstehen muss man
logischerweise zuerst wissen was genau
die hthis sind und woher sie kommen
wofür sie kämpfen ob sie eine religiöse
politische oder jihadistische Gruppe
sind und was die ayatollas im Iran mit
dieser ganzen Geschichte zu tun haben
denn passt gut auf wir reden hier über
eine sehr sehr ambitionierte
Gruppierung die eine Sch verdoren in
Riads
Allerwertesten werfen wir zunächst einen
Blick auf diese Karte ihr müsst nämlich
verstehen dass die huthi aus dem
nördlichen Teil des Jemen stammen
genauer gesagt aus der Region Saad die
an Saudiarabien grenzt seit 2011 hat
diese Gruppierung nicht nur die
Kontrolle über die Region Saat sonder
auch über die angrenzende Region im
Süden des Landes übernommen nach und
nach deenten die hui ihre Kontrolle über
große Teile des Landes aus und da die
hui eine saidische Gruppe sind also
Schiiten war die Konfrontation mit dem
sunitischen Saudiarabien
vorprogrammiert reat war sich darüber im
Klaren der Sieg der hui bedeutet dass
der Jemen Teil des iranischen
Machtbereichs geworden wäre und ihr
müsst nur einen Blick auf die Karte der
Region werfen um zu verstehen warum dies
eine Gefahr darstellte würde der Iran
den Jemen kontrollieren würde er damit
nicht nur Saudi-Arabien praktisch
umzingeln sondern auch eine der
wichtigsten Handelsstraßen der Welt
kontrollieren die Straße von BAB
almandab den ein und Ausgang zum Roten
Meer und damit jede Passage die alle
Schiffe die durch den Sueskanal wollen
passieren
müssen sicher habt ihr in den letzten
Jahren viel von den militärischen
Einsätzen der USA Frankreichs Japans und
Chinas in dem kleinen Land Djibouti
gehört eine noch nie daagewesene
Konzentration von marinestützpunkten ich
bin mir sicher dass er jetzt das hohe
Interesse dieser Mächte an Djibouti
versteht aber das ist noch nicht alles
seit 2004 als der Anführer der huthi
Hussein Barin alhui im Kampf getötet
wurde hat diese Gruppe einen langen
Prozess der Radikalisierung Durchl hört
euch mal ihren radikalen Slogan an allah
ist groß Tod für Amerika Tod für Israel
Fluch den Juden Sieg für den Islam etwas
von dem sie behaupten es sei
metaphorisch aber ich glaube kaum dass
das überzeugend wirkt tja wenn es ihnen
passt behaupten sie das alles sei nur
metaphorisch gemeint aber ist das
wirklich überzeugend tatsache ist dass
diese Gruppe im Jahr 2014 eindeutig die
Kontrolle über das Land anstrebte und
angesichts der Gefahr dass der Iran
durch eine zunehmend radikalisierte
Gruppe die Kontrolle über den Jemen
übert nehmen könnte Griff der
Kooperationsrat des Persischen Golfs
2015 militärisch
ein im März 2015 kündigten Saudi-Arabien
bachrein Kuweit Katar Jordanien die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate Ägypten
Marokko der Sudan und der Senegal eine
Militärintervention im Jemen an ihr Ziel
war es die Regierung zu unterstützen und
den Vormarsch der huti Rebellen im Land
zu stoppen die Kampagne wurde zu Lande
und aus der Luft durchgeführt und sollte
das Debüt der hochgerüsteten saudischen
Streitkräfte darstellen
dennoch sorgte die Intervention der
arabischen Golfstaaten für eine große
Überraschung ein erbitterter und gut
vorbereiteter Widerstand der hui mit dem
niemand gerechnet hatte 1 August 2019
jemenkrieg hui Raketenangriff auf
Militärparade tötet 32 Menschen 20
November 2021 hthi sagen drohenangriffe
zielten auf mehrere saudische Städte 26
dezember 2021 die hui haben 2015 430
Raketen und 851 drohen auf Saudi-Arabien
abgefeuert mit iranischer Unterstützung
ihrer eigenen Kenntnis des Geländes und
ihrer Verteidigungstaktik gelang es den
hui nicht nur die Offensive der
jemenitischen Regierung und ihrer
internationalen Verbündeten zu vereiteln
nein sie begannen 2019 sogar geziels
saudische öleinrichtungen Stellungen in
den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten und
bachrein anzugreifen sie gingen sogar s
weit dass sie bei ihren Offensivaktionen
ballistische Raketen einsetzten 29
November 2018 USA werben für neue für
iranische Waffen im jeemen und in
Afghanistan und so wurde der
jemenitische Bürgerkrieg zu einem
besonders tödlichen regionalen Krieg um
euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
schätzungen zufolge sind bereits fast
400.000 Menschen in einem Land mit etwas
mehr als 30 Millionen Einwohnern durch
den Krieg ums Leben gekommen soweit so
schlecht aber jetzt wo wir die husti
etwas besser kennen ist es an der Zeit
in die Gewässer des Roten Meers
einzutauchen was genau ist in diesem
Gebiet los welche Risiken wirgt die
Kontrolle der huthi über diese wichtige
Seepassage ist der kommerzielle transit
durch das Rote Meer wirklich in Gefahr
[Musik]
aufgepasst die Rebellen und das
Meer das Rote Meer wird von
Saudi-Arabien Ägypten und dem Sudan
flankiert und ist eines der Tore zum
Sueskanal es wird geschätzt dass etwa
12% des gesamten Welthandels über diesen
Kanal abgewickelt werden und bis zu
einem Drittel der Container die um den
Globus reisen genau aus diesem Grund
wird die Offensive der huthi in diesen
Gewässern mit großer Sorge betrachtet
die Angriffe der huthi finden vor allem
in der Meerenge BAB almandab statt die
das Horn von Afrika von der Arabischen
Halbinsel trennt diese Zone hat eine
Länge von 1 km aber in der Breite misst
sie nur 29 km und dies macht wie euch
vorstellen könnt große Schiffe zu einer
attraktiven Beute für die huthi eine der
Lösungen die einige Unternehmen gewählt
haben ist die Umleitung ihrer Schiffe um
das Cup der guten Hoffnung südlich von
Südafrika mit anderen Worten sie
entscheiden sich dafür den gesamt
afrikanischen Kontinent zu umfahren das
Problem ist dass dies viel länger dauert
und viel höhere Kosten verursacht die
Umleitung über das K der guten Hoffnung
verlängert die Transitzeit um 7 bis 10
Tage aber das hängt davon ab wo sich das
Schiff befindet wenn die Entscheidung
zur Umleitung getroffen wurde je nachdem
wo sich das Schiff befindet kann es
sogar zu einer noch längeren Verzögerung
von zwe bis vier Wochen kommen wenn es
das Rote Meer umfahren musste die
Umleitung über Afrika würde die Fahrzeit
zwischen Südasien und den USA um 7 Tage
und die Fahrzeit zwischen Asien und
Europa über das K Hoffnung um 10 Tage
verlängern und Schätzungen zufolge
belaufen sich die zusätzlichen Transit
und Treibstoffkosten auf mehr als 2
Millionen US-Dollar pro Schiff und
natürlich reden wir hier über eine Menge
Schiffe um euch eine Vorstellung zu
geben jeden Tag durchqueren
durchschnittlich 50 Schiffe den
zugeskanal das sind 1500 Schiffe pro
Monat wir sprechen also von potenziellen
Kosten in Höhe von mehreren Millionen
oder gab Milliarden Dollar pro Monat
hinzu kommt dass die Operation der huti
im roten mehr ein neues Niveau an
technischen Fähigkeiten zeigen das weit
über das hinausgeht was man aus der
Vergangenheit z.B von Piraten
kennt und auch über das was man bisher
von den hui kannte wir sprechen davon
dass zu den bereits bekannten
Fähigkeiten zur Manipulation
ballistischer Raketen nur noch
hochkomplexe taktische Aktion
hinzukommen wie das Entern eines
Schiffes von einem Hubschrauber aus oder
die Steuerung und Verfolgung von
Handelsschiffen auf offener See nach
Schätzungen des Washingtoner
institutioner Ostpolitik verfügen die HU
wahrscheinlich über haftmen
torpedowerfer mit Kurzstreckenraketen
bewaffnete Schnellboote oder sogar
antischümarchflugkörper sowie über
operative Fähigkeiten am Boden und in
der Luft aber aufgepasst denn
theoretisch könnte die Situation nicht
nur ein Problem für den Welthandel
sondern vor allem eine Tragödie für die
Wirtschaft und die Stabilität der ganzen
Region darstellen und warum nun weil das
Rote Meer große Hoffnungen bei den
Ländern in der Region weckte
insbesondere natürlich bei Saudi-Arabien
habt ihr z.B schon von Neum gehört nun
das hier ist es das Rote Meer liegt
zwischen zwei Kontinenten und grenzt an
sechs Länder in Afrika und vier in nen
Osten und etwa 10% des weltwe weiten
Handels werden über seine Gewässer
abgewickelt bis 2050 wird sich das BEP
am Roten Meer voraussichtlich mehr als
verdreifachen nämlich von 1,8 Billionen
auf 6,1 Billionen Dollar und der Handel
wird voraussichtlich um mehr als das
Fünffache wachsen nämlich von 881
Milliarden auf 4,7 Billionen Dollar
solange die huste die Kontrolle haben
könnten all diese großen Erwartungen zu
Nichte gemacht werden und all das meine
Lieben Zuschauer erklärt warum die
westlichen Länder und insbesondere die
USA die Sache selbst in die Hand nehmen
das Problem ist natürlich wie immer dass
eine weitere Intervention den Konflikt
eskalieren könnte und zwar vor allem
einen Konflikt den der den Iran gegen
die USA ausspielen könnte hört es gut
[Musik]
zu ein Aufstieg in drei
Schritten im Jahr 2022 wurde der
presidential leadership Council kurz PLC
gegründet um die Regierung der
jemenitischen Republik zu stärken
Präsident alhadi übertrug damit seine
Befugnisse an einen achtköpfigen
präsidialführungsrat unter dem Vorsitz
von Rashad alalimi und durch diesen
Schritt wurden die Beziehungen zu den
USA erheblich gestärkt es handelte sich
um einen weiteren großen Erfolg Anthony
blinkons der eine der aktivsten US
ausminister seit Menschen gedinkken ist
ja ein wahres
Multitalent
[Musik]
das Problem ist dass dies die und
insbesondere ihre iranischen
Unterstützer dazu veranlas ihre
Bemühungen Vorort zu verelfach was den
Konflikt auf einen neuen eskalationspfad
brachte die Situation im Jemen passt
perfekt zu dem was man einen
Stellvertreterkrieg nennt ein Konflikt
der durch den nicht enden wollenden
Kampf zwischen Saudi-Arabien und dem
Iran aufrecht erhalten wird und jetzt
wird es natürlich noch schlimmer
ursprünglich kämpften die hui mit
iranischeer Unterstützung gegen die
jemenitische zentraleregierung bis zu
diesem Zeitpunkt war der Konflikt
relativ lokal begrenzt Saudi-Arabien
führte daraufhin eine arabische
Koalition an um gegen die husti
vorzugehen was diese dazu veranlasste
ihre Waffen nicht nur gegen die
jemenitische Regierung sondern auch
gegen ihre Nachbaren zu richten und so
begann die regionale Eskalation tja und
jetzt haben die hui Israel und westliche
Länder die mit Israel verbündet sind ins
Visier
genommen SP um dieser Bedrohung zu
begegnen haben die USA wie eingangs
erwähnt eine gemeinsame marineoperation
im Roten Meer gestartet die Operation
prosperity Guardian an dieser Kampagne
soll sich nicht nur die Koalition am
Persischen Golf beteiligen sondern auch
kombinierte Seestreitkräfte aus
Großbritannien Italien Frankreich Kanada
sowie niederländische und norwegische
logistikkräfte 15 Januar 2024
Deutschland schckt Fregatte Hessen ins
Rote Meer die EU plant eine neue Mission
um den Seeverkehr im Roten Meer gegen HU
die Angriffe zu sichern Deutschland will
sich mit der Fregatte Hessen beteiligen
und auch Waffengewalt einsetzen um
Raketen und drohen der huthi abzufangen
theoretisch soll diese internationale
Truppe die Ordnung im Roten Meer
wiederherstellen und dafür sorgen dass
es jederzeit frei befahren werden kann
praktisch handelt es sich jedoch um eine
Koalition der Inkonsequenz die mehr
schwächeer als Stärke demonstriert wieso
genau habe ich in zwei separaten Videos
auf meinem persönlichen Kanal
auseinander genommen und ich werde sie
euch verlinken dort werde ich euch auch
bald eine mögliche tragfähige und
nachhaltige Lösung des ganzen Problems
vorstellen kleiner Spoiler es geht darum
den Iran aufs Kreuz zu legen und mit
seinen eigenen Waffen zu schlagen aber
wie genau werde ich euch dort erklären
bis dahin eröffnen sich nämlich nur zwei
äußerst komplexe
Szenarien erstens entpuckt sich der
bewaffnete Konflikt im Jemen der
eigentlich ein Kampf zwischen hui
Rebellen und der Zentralregierung war
nun als ein komplexes Geflecht aus
arabischen und nicht arabischen
Interessen mit einem verwirrenden
religiösen Hintergrund und viel mehr
Risiken sollten die USA die hui erneut
als terroristische Organisation
einstufen würden die Kämpfe eine weitere
Wendung nehmen da ihnen die
institutionelle Anerkennung fehlen würde
um einen Waffenstillstand
auszuhandeln 17 Januar 2024 Regierung
beiden will huti Rebell wieder als
speziell gekennzeichnete globale
Terrororganisation einstufen zweitens
bereitet das Voranschreiten der
israelischen Offensive im Gazastreifen
den regionalen Akteuren nun
Kopfzerbrechen da die hutiofensive am
Roten Meer eine direkte Vergeltung für
Israels Aktionen auf palästinensischem
Gebiet ist dies wäre das erste Anzeichen
dafür dass die Angriffe der Hamas und
die Reaktion Israels in einem viel
größeren Problem enden könnten viele
Experten weisen darauf hin dass der Iran
so viele Krisenherde wie möglich
aktivieren will um die saudischen und
amerikanischen strategischen Fähigkeiten
zu überwältigen und genau das würde
Teheran mit der Situation im Jemen
erreichen 16 Januar 2024 USA greifen
vier raketenstellungen der hui an Iran
greift angebliche israelische
spionagebasis im Irak an das Chor der
islamischen revolutionsgarten zerstörte
am späten Montag das angebliche Spionage
Quartier des israelischen Geheimdienstes
Mossad in der irakischkurdischen Stadt
Erbil wie die staatliche
Nachrichtenagentur der Islamischen
Republik mitteilte wie die Financial
Times unter Berufung auf kurdische
Behörden berichtet wurden bei dem
Angriff vier Menschen getötet und sechs
weitere verwundet der Raketenangriff sei
ein klarer AK der Aggression gegen sein
Land sagte der irakische
Ministerpräsident Mohammed als sudani am
Dienstag der Angriff ist mit Sicherheit
eine gefährliche Entwicklung die die
starken Beziehungen zwischen dem Irak
und dem Iran untergräbt sagte er die
Situation im Jemen wird nämlich sehr
hässlich werden die huthis haben es
geschafft den Krieg zwischen Israel und
der Hamas über ihre Grenzen
hinauszutragen und ich hoffe ihr habt
jetzt ein besseres Verständnis für die
jüngste Militäraktion der USA und
deswegen sind die Fragen jetzt erstmal
an euch gerichtet was haltet ihr von der
Operation prosperity Guardian denkt ihr
die Luftschläge werden ausreichen haltet
ihr es für richtig dass sich der Westen
in diesen Konflikt einmischt inwiew weit
kann der Iran die Operation der hui im
Jemen weiterhin unterstützen und werden
wir neue Krisenherde in der Region sehen
wie immer sind wir auf eure angeregte
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt
ihm bitte ein Like teilt es mit euren
Freunden und auch auf sozialen Medien
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit der uns
helft dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald